Okay, so now that we've had a look at some of the light types
and some of the basic properties of lights,
let's go ahead and take a look at one of the lighting systems
of Unreal Engine 5, which is going to be Lumen.
So the topics that we're going to cover in this video
are what is Lumen, how we set it up,
some quality control to make sure that we get the best out of Lumen,
some tips and tricks, as well as some visualizers
that we can take a look at to troubleshoot some of the issues
that we might have with Lumen.
So when it comes to what Lumen is,
it's Unreal Engine 5's fully dynamic global illumination
and reflection system, which is designed for the next-gen consoles
as well as high-end PCs.
Now, what's really cool about Lumen is that you're not dependent
on high-end ray tracing GPU
to get ray tracing, essentially.
And another thing that's really cool about Lumen
is that it renders diffuse into reflection with infinite bounces
and indirect specular reflections in loud detail environments
at scales ranging from millimeters to kilometers.
Now, the thing, and the important thing about that
is it provides infinite diffuse bounces,
which means when it comes to the light bleed in between
or the color bleed in between surfaces in Unreal,
we aren't limited to a particular number of bounces.
We have infinite bounces for that, which is really cool.
Now, another thing that's great about it
is that when used in combination with Nanite's virtualized geometry,
it allows us to have very, very, very detailed geometry
and also achieve full resolution shading
while computing that indirect lighting cheaper than ever before.
Skylighting is also solved as part of Lumen's final gather process,
and that includes sky shadowing,
which allows for indoor spaces to be much darker than outdoor lighting,
and you get much more natural-feeling effects.
And another thing to keep in mind is that it also provides
slightly lower quality, lower illumination for light translucency
and volumetric fog, although that's improving as we speak,
and we hope that future releases actually make this really, really cool.
Another cool feature about Unreal is that it supports emissive materials
at no additional performance cost.
There is a limit to how small and bright the objects can be
that emit light, so it's actually always a little bit better
to use actual lights than this gear is.
Another thing to keep in mind is troubleshooting these things
that can be harder to solve than manually placed lights,
but it is still a really cool feature to have,
especially for larger meshes.
When it comes to reflections,
it solves indirect specular or reflections
for the full range of the material's roughness value,
and another great thing is that the fused golden animation
in the shadow skylight can be seen in reflections,
as well as being supported in clear coat materials,
which is really, really cool.
What does it replace, then?
It replaces the skylight with ambient occlusion
or unshadowed skylights.
It replaces any form of screen space
global illumination system that we might have had.
It replaces full-on hardware ray tracing global illumination,
as well as any third-party global illumination solutions.
Now, how do we set this up?
To set Lumen up, you just need to make a few changes
on the project settings.
On the project settings, you want to go to the Rendering tab
and make sure that the dynamic global illumination system
is set to Lumen, that the reflections and their method
are set to Lumen as well.
And this should happen automatically,
but if it doesn't, just make sure you double-check
the Generate Mesh Distance fields is on.
And another thing that you might need to do
is change your default RHI to DirectX 12
so that you can have Shader Model 6 enabled.
This is required for some of the visualizers.
From here on, any other changes that we want to do
down the line for changing quality and things like that
will be done via the post-process volume.
Now, if we take a look at some of the things
that we can do to get a slightly better reflections,
if you have a good enough card,
is one cool thing about Lumen is that it can form
a little bit of a hybrid system with actual ray tracing.
So you can set up your reflections to be ray traced.
So to get better reflections,
and if your card can handle it, as I say,
you can change these settings to change the ray lighting mode
to hit lighting for reflections,
and the software ray tracing mode to detail tracing.
When it comes to quality control
and how we can change the quality for performance
in terms of Lumen's scene quality settings,
we can go to the post-process volume
and change the following things.
So if we change the Lumen scene lighting quality,
it scales the actual quality of Lumen.
So larger scales on this will mean
that the Lumen scene is calculated with higher fidelity,
which will be visible in the reflections, for example,
but the larger the value, the higher the GPU cost.
And you'll hear me say this a lot,
especially when we start tweaking values
to get better detail.
The Lumen scene detail controls the size of instances
that can be calculated in the scene.
So the larger the value,
the smaller the objects that can be calculated,
but again, at the cost of GPU.
The Lumen scene view distance,
so if you set the maximum view distance
so that the scene maintains, sorry,
that sets the maximum view distance of the scene
that Lumen maintains for ray tracing against,
the large values will help with sky shadowing
and global illumination, but again, at the cost of GPU.
And then we have the Lumen final gather quality
which scales Lumen's final gather quality,
and again, the larger the values, the less noise,
but the higher the GPU cost.
Now, some more advanced settings here
are the lighting update quality settings.
So if you change the Lumen quality update speed,
it will control how much Lumen scene is allowed to cache
the lighting results that help with performance.
So the larger the value,
the faster those changes are gonna propagate,
but the higher the GPU cost.
And when it comes to the final gather lighting update speed,
it controls how much Lumen final gather
is allowed to cache those lighting results,
just like before.
And again, the larger the values,
the faster those changes are gonna propagate,
but again, at the cost of your GPU.
When it comes to reflections,
to get higher quality reflections,
you wanna change under the Lumen reflection sections,
if you change the values of the quality here,
it will reduce the noise in the reflections,
however, higher GPU cost.
And then one tip is to change the ray lighting mode
to hit lighting for reflections,
and that'll be the highest quality,
but again, increase GPU cost.
Now, some visualizers that you might find handy
to troubleshoot some of the issues
that you might be having can be found.
So under the show tab,
you've got under the Lumen section here,
a lot of information that you can take
to actually see and visualize any of these changes.
And then if you go under the lit or the view mode,
yeah, if you go to Lumen,
you can also see the overall Lumen scene,
how the reflections are doing
and what the surface cast is doing.
Now, to get into some tips and tricks
that you might find handy when it comes to using Lumen.
So Lumen does not currently support
fully mirrored reflections.
It's on the roadmap, but currently is limited.
It does not support any static lights,
which I think would make sense
considering that we are using
a fully dynamic global illumination system.
Now, however, one cool thing
is that if you do disable a lot of static lighting,
it can help with some of the overhead
and it makes sure your Lumen AR process
is working with no hindrances.
Now, another cool thing is that Lumen
does support material and inclusion,
which is really good for characters.
It does not currently support world position offsets.
So if you have it active in a project,
any of those materials that are offset
inverts through the material
will become a little bit blurry in the movement.
It does support all physical lights,
but as long as the mobility of those lights
is set to movable.
And a couple of cool little tricks,
especially if you're trying to soften your shadows,
is the source angle on the main directional light
that will change and soften your shadows
for that dominant directional light.
And if you change the source radius,
the larger the source radius,
the softer your shadows are going to be.
So those are some tips and tricks that you can find
handy when working with Lumen.
Okay, so here's some additional resources if you need them.
After this, we'll be taking a look at Nanite
and its virtual shadow map.